[Musique]
m
au moment d'un victoire a fortiori quand
tout le monde se tourne vers celui qui a
réussi l'incroyable défi de se faire
élire après apprécié l'endroit puisque
c'était ou s'attendait quand même est-ce
que ce soit plutôt à la gauche qui soit
consacrée par le suffrage universel en
et ça n'est pas le cas donc nicolas
sarkozy apparaît vraiment comme un chef
politique qui a réussi un tour de force
de force exceptionnelle il permet à la
droite française de s'élargir dans ce
que alain juppé appelle les deux bouts
de l'omelette c'est à dire d'avoir des
électeurs de centre gauche
sociaux-démocrates les strauss-kahniens
en gros qui vont voter pour nicolas
sarkozy mais également des électeurs
d'extrême droite
ils votaient genre et le pen et qui vont
voter pour nicolas sarkozy est donc tout
en défendant l'idée d'une droite
décomplexée capable de reprendre un
certain nombre d idées qui venait du
front national vous faisait aussi
beaucoup d'efforts pour montrer à la
droite libérale et européennes qui
étaient avec elle et qui portait
beaucoup des sujets qui était important
pour elle
je ne vous trahirai pas je ne vous
mentirai pas je ne vous décevrai pas
[Musique]
le 6 mai 2007 nicolas sarkozy est élu
président de la république la droite
était alors au sommet hélas un chef
incontesté et a toujours des tensions
mais la force en 2007 de la droite c'est
qu'il ya un leader incontesté qui vient
d'être élu et donc forcément nicolas
sarkozy arrive à rassembler tout le
monde même si déjà certains sarkozystes
comme patrick devedjian ont ce petit
trait d'humour en disant ce serait bien
que l'ouverture se fassent jusqu'au
sarkozystes parce que ça commence a
moins bien fonctionné
à partir du moment où les sondages et
les élections sont montre qu'il ya des
défaites à venir et que vous perdez le
pouvoir les élections régionales les
élections départementales et les
élections sénatoriales vont être perdues
par l'ump
donc là on voit que la machine commence
à s'enrayer
et du coup nicolas sarkozy en plus
appartement où le front national
commence à se reconstruire se
reconstituer sous la houlette de marine
le pen
il va hypertrophié sa jambe droite et la
jambe gauche va devenir de plus en plus
réduite sous l'ère nicolas sarkozy l'ump
subit des revers électoraux
mais le grand parti de droite connaît
aussi des succès élections européennes
de 2009 où le parti de nicolas sarkozy
l'ump fait de mémoire 29 ou 30 % des
voix très bons résultats alors que ont
considéré un an plus tôt qu'il avait
entre en planches et le début d'un
déclin inéluctable
il ya aussi un élément qui à mon avis
n'est pas neutre c'est à dire que à la
base l'ump c'est le rassemblement de
trois familles de droite
les gaullistes les libéraux et les
centristes sauf que ça fonctionne si
tout le monde
se retrouvent dans des postes or si vous
regardez bien le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
les principaux postes sont trustées par
les anciens rpr et au bout de cinq ans
voilà il constate que y'a jamais rien
pour eux il ya eu un moment la
possibilité pour nicolas sarkozy en la
rentrée 2010 de changer de premier
ministre et il met en scène jean louis
borloo figures centristes et donc là ça
aurait pu permettre de pallier la
difficulté qui était que les affaires
prenait toute la place et finalement il
ne le fait pas il laisse françois fillon
et là il ya une grosse déception il ya
une prise de conscience chez ces gens là
qu'au fond le rpr ne partagera jamais le
pouvoir au sein de l'ump et donc il a il
ya un premier première vague de départs
autour de jean-louis borloo pour essayer
de de faire vivre
de peser dans un rapport de forces qu'on
arrive l'élection présidentielle de 2012
l'image de nicolas sarkozy est écornée
mais il reste le candidat naturel de la
droite
on est encore dans la partie et la
période de la droite où il ya un leader
presque incontesté c'est à dire qu'il a
été élu quelques années avant l'elysée
et donc pour personne on irait remettre
en cause son leadership pour être le
candidat de la droite ça veut pas dire
que d'autres n'ont pas envie ça veut pas
dire que certains ne le conteste pas
mais il ya une sorte d'évidence qui
s'impose et qui n'a plus aujourd'hui les
deux bouts de l'omelette qui est avait
pu et élargie selon l'expression d'alain
juppé en 2007 se sont totalement
rétrécit parce que nicolas sarkozy est
allé trop sûr sur un côté vers l'extrême
droite et donc a fait fuir une partie de
l'électorat de centre gauche mais il n'a
pas récupéré pour autant l'électorat
d'extrême droite pour la raison
principale qui est l absence de
résultats l'autre élément aussi qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que
l'électorat populaire a déserté aussi la
droite est tout un électorat que nicolas
sarkozy avait su convaincre notamment
sur le travailler plus gagner plus tout
cet électorat-là d'ouvriers le
questionnaire de femmes seules qui
travaillent dans la distribution qui
grâce aux heures supplémentaires avaient
pu augmenter son pouvoir d'achat soir de
la défaite moi je suis à la mutualité
parce que je suis la soirée et c'est
vrai qu'il ya énormément de tristesse
chez les militants dans l'équipe de
campagne on les voit tous pleuré et pour
certains s'effondrer parce que il ya
quand même eu cette idée que il pouvait
l'emporter même s'il y avait françois
hollande qui était donné vainqueur donc
voilà il ya une grosse déception dans la
salle et arrive ce moment où il ya
nicolas sarkozy qui prononce son
discours de sortie et un discours qui
est plutôt jugée réussie même si
il n'y a pas de portes fermées pour la
suite quand une défaite c'est le numéro
un et qui emporte la première
responsable
à droite normalement il ya un chef il ya
fatalement des tricheries qui vont se
produire mais dans un moment très très
dur de crise en fond de luttes
d'ambition politique
[Musique]